when you first saw star wars did carrie
fisher
must have had some impact on you when
you first saw her in that iconic role
i think she definitely planted a seed in
my mind
uh that's what i've seen yeah that seed
that seed that explains it all uh and we
were discussing it earlier about there
being
i remember even in my infant mind
thinking there's a woman
that's direct and smart and in control
and strong-minded and that's different
and that's exciting
and then the seed was planted from the
screen
into my mind where it lives now right
right
also the command to kill and kill again
peter what was your experience were you
exposed to star wars i was at a young
age yeah
i grew up watching star wars towers
would come on tv
on public holidays we only had two tv
channels so everyone watched
where was this in kenya and who was the
character that you were most
drawn to would you say right away
what does that mean i don't know
[Laughter]
she's just passed out again
my favorite the character that i
loved the most was r2d2 r2d2
yeah actually carrie fisher was
definitely up there as well
oh good you're up there with the trash
can that goes bleep bleep
and we're both we're the shortest
characters
so you wouldn't know about that but
anyway yeah no i i really was drawn to
how
she spoke her mind and she was very
witty too princess leia and that was
something that was
really exciting to see a woman who spoke
her mind and got away
um that was planted in my head too no
doubt and of course now
with the uh with the new film so many
strong
women characters talked to jj earlier
and that was something he he
intentionally
wanted to not just have it be uh
leia who's a strong character but
actually create many more he wanted to
dilute it
and make it he wanted to take what you
had started
yeah and just make it less than
important by having it all over the
place
incredible incredible carrie uh do
you have advice uh for these ladies
about
entering the star wars universe it
obviously had a huge impact on your life
they're just getting into it now
what would you tell them don't go
through the cast like wildfire
and they make you wear white all the
time to take away from that
you know porn quality that you have
so don't do that either and you'll be
fine why did no one tell us this andy i
don't know
we have man worked our way through
everyone on conan
slept with all these people everyone
here everybody i have
had multiple times yeah satisfying
not for anybody fan stuff is fun for you
though
well someone said they thought about me
every day from when they were 12
to when they were 22 and i said every
day and they said well
four times a day so
that's what can happen for you i went
oh thank you right
and then you married him twice
then he left me for a man so uh